un nuevo paso en las relaciones entre
Cuba y Estados Unidos washington reabrió
Las puertas de su embajada para los
servicios consulares tras años de pausa
los cubanos expresaron su satisfacción
para realizar cualquier trámite
migratorio rumbo Norte tenían que viajar
hacia otro país muchos cubanos se
desesperan y eso eso es una locura eso
yo no lo hago lo importante de la
embajada aquí es eso hice legal y sin
problema el cierre parcial de la
representación diplomática
estadounidense se dio en el año 2017 dos
años después del restablecimiento de las
relaciones con la Habana durante el
gobierno de Barack Obama la
administración Trump clausuró la sede
luego de que varios miembros del
personal diplomático estadounidense
presentaran dolencias principalmente
neurológicas tanto en la Habana como en
otras ciudades del mundo sin embargo fue
bautizado como el síndrome de La Habana
y según hipótesis se trata de ataques
sónicos la van a reaccionó a la nueva
apertura de la mano de su canciller
Aunque criticó que la medida no aplica
para los no inmigrantes
reanudación del proceso de Divisas para
migrantes cubanos desde embajada en la
Habana es un paso necesario y correcto
aún no incluye visas de no inmigrante lo
que obstaculiza visitas familiares e
intercambios culturales deportivos y
científicos para los que cubas sigue
abierta la crisis económica en Cuba
grabada por la pandemia y los efectos
del embargo económico que la Casa Blanca
impone sobre la isla han hecho que cerca
de 250.000 cubanos hayan abandonado el
país de manera ilegal hacia la Unión
Americana tan solo en 2022 este hecho se
dan un complejo contexto migratorio para
Washington que intenta frenar uno de los
mayores flujos de migrantes de los
últimos años en su frontera